we have to understand what we're good
and bad at and you have to let go of
what you're bad at you have to if you're
naturally bad at singing like I am you
shouldn't put your career and your life
in a position to become a professional
singer it's a bad idea and I think a lot
of people want to be entrepreneurs and
business people because it sounds
glamorous to make a million dollars a
year on your terms on your own schedule
the problem is it's a talent it is a
talent to be a business person and you
can become the best version of yourself
right but it's here it's like being
pretty like you can become prettier you
can get tans you can work out you know
but mom and dad had sex at the right
moment and your nose is your nose now
you can have plastic surgery there is no
plastic surgery in business so I need
people to wrap their head around that I
don't know how to help people do more of
it other than scream at the top of my
lungs about it for the rest of my life
but anything that can help you get into
a place where you can not dwell not
complain not allowed the negativity to
seep in it will bring you enormous
dividends and whether that's a life
coach or a therapist or or a two-month
retreat to reset or I don't know but
whatever it is please please please
realize how big of a deal it is
you